ja aber mal von meiner seite vielen dank
für das referat und wir werden jetzt
heute anschließend an dieses referat
noch einmal ganz kurz auf leibnitz
eingehen und wir hatten uns drei also
ein paar leitfrage mal überlegt wie
grenzt sich leibnitz von anderen
theorien des bösen ab könnte man sich
überlegen für dritte leibnitz eine
private und eine perversion theorie des
bösen wie fern kann leibnitz das böse
mit der trägheit vergleich vielleicht
kommen wir da noch drauf sagt er nämlich
am ende dieses textes und jetzt haben
wir hier
ich habe also während des referats ein
bisschen mitgeschrieben und versuche das
ganze mein sonne im schema zu bringen
also wir haben gott dem diese drei
attribute dazu kommt diese drei
prädikate allmächtig all gültig und
allwissend allwissend ist so ein
bisschen meine augen darüber kann man
diskutieren hier nicht so zentral als
wichtigste ins all machen all güte ich
weiß garnicht hatten sie allwissend auch
erwähnt geld deswegen genau aber ich
hatte es noch hinzugenommen aber es ist
nicht so zentral weil er allmächtig ist
der weiß auch alles
wobei wer allmächtig ist mustergültig
sein was würden sie sagen muss dass
wenige derjenige diejenige der
allmächtig ist albig seien nicht
unbedingt als wir euch jetzt nicht
irgendwie ein
diese beiden konnten
während diese an güte doch zentral seien
schein- und diese diese prädikate die
konflikt ihren natürlich vor allem die
alten die konflikte mit dem leiden der
welt und dieses leid in der welt das
kann man jetzt wie sie auch richtig
gezeigt haben
in einem unterscheidet einmal um
metaphysik um einmal moral und einmal um
physikum und diese drei im haller diese
treiben maladie hängen wiederum
miteinander zusammen das haben sie auch
gut gezeigt also dieses mal um physik um
das volk irgendwie aus dem mann um moral
könnte man sagen ist so die strafe oder
das ist jetzt die frage wie folgt dass
beide mal um moral und manchen physikum
folgen irgendwie aus diesem mal um
metaphysik um wer von ihnen weiß noch
mal wir kann auch mal ganz kurz zu sagen
was dieses mal um metaphysik um
eigentlich ist bei leighton
wir haben sie im referat schon kurz
gehört aber das ist eine ganz ganz
zentrale sache bleibt aber bisher bei
augustinus hatten wir das nur mit diesen
zwei maler zu tun mal um moral und mal
um physik um das moralische übel also
die sünde dass ich etwas böses tue ich
über ein mord ich lüge ich stehle solche
dinge das sind moralische übel oder ich
leide an einer krankheit ist oder ich
leide ein irgendwie leid infolge einer
naturkatastrophe das ist einmal um
physikum aber wie verhält sich jetzt das
manometer für sie kommt nichts was ist
das nochmal wer kann ihnen kann das noch
mal kurz sagen oder was könnte es sein
wenn sie sich mal erschließen wollen
einfach wir kommen da auch nochmal heute
im text darauf zu sprechen natürlich
schauen sie doch mal einfach vom wort
kommt metaphysik um also ist es kein
übel dass sich jetzt in der welt konkret
unbedingt vollzieht krankheit konkrete
krankheit konkretes moralische sondern
es ist irgendwie allgemeiner oder
grundlegender die könnte man diese noch
grundlegendere dimension erklären ja
sie vergessen
genau theorie würde ich jetzt nicht
sagen aber so die rahmenbedingungen
könnte man fast sagen die
rahmenbedingungen oder wie sie richtig
sagen diese
dieser grund der urgrund dieser beiden
und man kann immer noch man ja woher
kommt jetzt überhaupt diese tatsache
dass ich krank werden kann dass ich von
einer krankheit befahren würde woher
kommt die tatsache dass ich moralisch
handeln könnte ich muss es ja nicht nur
moralisch handeln könnte ich muss es ja
nicht immer tun
ich könnte es auch überhaupt nicht tun
was ziemlich unwahrscheinlich ist woher
kommt überhaupt diese kunden
man hat schon mit
wenn man sich selber vorstellen dass
diese freiheit zurück
die man der fantasie ausleben wollte als
ich würde nicht sagen dass dieses
metaphysischer jetzt nur die fantasie
ist sondern dass wir jetzt gerade was
eine gute frage trotzdem das wäre jetzt
meine frage an die ganze gruppe
denn wir hatten uns gesagt dass man mit
der physiker betrifft die frage warum
können wir moralisch böse handel und
warum können wir krankheiten erleiden
was ist die antwort auf diese frage
warum warum machen um physikum warum man
um moral was ist der grund ist ganz
einfache sache eigentlich unter welchen
bedingungen können diese zwei mal nur
auftreten können diese zwei maler
auftreten bei gott kann gott seine
begriffe nach physisches übel erleiden
sie haben sich
wir sind
wichtig da die einfach nicht und
deswegen kann ja auch nicht nötig und
nicht immer möchte ich haben
genau wie könnte man das nennen er ist
abgestuft mit einem begriff er ist im
gegensatz zu gott
genau er ist nicht perfekt er ist
endlich sterblicher es individuum
begrenzt hat grenzen
und diese grenzen sind metaphysischer
aber das müssen wir natürlich noch
genauer begreifen warum sollte denn die
endlichkeit die menschliche endlichkeit
ein metaphysisches übels sein könnte man
es jetzt fragen hat jemand eine idee
warum leiht uns diese endlichkeit
metaphysisches übel nimmt
ich meinerseits kann man sagen gut das
metaphysische ist es insofern
metaphysisch als ist der grund ist und
der grund den nennen wir jetzt mal
metaphysisch die endlichkeit aber da
kommt noch eine weitere dimension
spielen wollten sie gerade was dazu
sagen ja
es gibt in der welt daher muss man sich
ja immer dann fragen wie hängt die
existenz teufels mit der existenz gottes
zusammen könnte gott als allmächtiger
gültiger sein teufel überhaupt zulassen
der von ihm unabhängig ist das ist halt
die frage wo der teufel spielt ja auch
bereit jetzt nicht so eine große rolle
genauso ist ein möglicher punkt wir
geben es gleich ein text rein ich gebe
nur noch einen hinweis dieses
metaphysische hat auch immer
letztendlich mit gott zu tun und gottes
schöpfung strategie oder gottes wort
gottes schöpfung produkt also aus der
allmacht gottes aus der schöpfung gottes
aus der logik der schöpfung könnte man
sagen gottes geht letztendlich dieses
manko metaphysik um hervor
das hängt damit aufs engste zusammen wir
hatten das auch im referat kurz gehört
als sie gesagt haben gott konnte glaube
ich keine wesen schöpfen die so sind wie
er
das geht nicht gott kann nicht einen
anderen gott schaffen der perfekt ist
das scheint nach leibnitz irgendwie
widersprüchlich zu sein gott musste wenn
erschöpft notwendigerweise oder gemäß
dem prinzip des verstandes natürlich ein
endliches wesen schaffen und mit dieser
endlichkeit die aus dieser schöpfungs
logik hervorgeht haben wir irgendwie
diese zwei maler hier schon angelegt
natürlich jetzt nicht unbedingt
notwendig dass der mensch
notwendigerweise sündigen muss aber der
möglichkeit zumindest nach sie noch ganz
kurz
sieben leben in der es möglich ist das
quasi er ist nicht nur auf die
beschränkung
ja da haben sie noch einen guten punkt
erwähnt denen wir auch im referat gehört
hatten wie wird gott noch einmal
charakterisiert wird hat zwei ein
vermögen
sie haben das im referat ziel klar
herausgearbeitet was für welche vermögen
hat gott
welche erkenntnis kräfte welche kräfte
hat er habe schon fast gesagt also gott
hat einerseits diese prädikate
allmächtig all gültig allwissend er hat
aber auch noch vermögen die auch der
mensch hat könnte man sagen
wissen sie es er hat einmal einen
verstand und was gab es noch das hat mir
gut gefallen im referat ja
ich denke verstanden vernunft kann man
jetzt mal in einen topf werfen erstmal
aber sie hatten das im referat gesagt
dass es noch jemanden was noch hinzu
kommen neben dem verstand gottes kommt
noch ein vermögen hinzu als eine kraft
die auch der mensch hat aber natürlich
nicht in dieser weise schauen wir gerade
wo es im referat ist vernunft und
verstand fassen wir zusammen schauen sie
mal auf der zweiten seite in der hälfte
dieser erste strichpunkt das erste pfeil
den sie da haben wo sie geschrieben
haben mit der differenzierung zwischen
gottes verstand und dessen willen
gelingt es leibnitz die prinzipien des
bösen gute figur leeres prinzipien zu
vereinbaren der wille ist auch noch ein
ganz wichtiges vermögen der wille und
aus dieser dieser komplexen verlogenheit
von wille und verstand in gott durch
diese unterscheidung dieser zwei
vermögen in gold versucht leibnitz zu
erklären dass sich diese existenz dieser
maler in der welt dieses leiden mit
seinen ganzen prädikaten allmächtig kaid
al gültigkeit allwissenheit verträgt das
ist die strategie durch diese
unterscheidung bleibt uns das ganze
lösen
und jetzt gehen wir mal einen text also
jetzt haben wir sagen die
rahmenbedingungen uns alle mal
angeschaut als ein hintergrund uns jetzt
beziehen wir mal die ganzen text stellen
wir uns noch anschauen wollen auf diese
skizze ja ich lese mal kurz vor also auf
seite 95 die schwierigkeiten kann man in
zwei klassen einteilen die einen stamm
aus der menschlichen freiheit sind diese
scheibe der göttliche natur
unverträglich zu sein muss der noch
notwendig angenommen werden um schuld
und strafbarkeit des menschen
aufrechtzuerhalten
die anderen haben es mit dem verhalten
gott das zu tun diese habe einen zu
großen anteil an der existenz des bösen
selbst wenn der mensch frei während auch
seinen anteil daran hätte dieses
verhalten scheint mit der göttlichen
güte heiligkeit ungerechtigkeit in
widerspruch zu stehen
da gott am physischen wie moralischen
übel mit wirk und zwar hier auf
moralische dort auf physische weisen ja
also gott steht aufgrund seiner
mächtigkeit irgendwie die kausal
relation zu diesen leiden in der welt
und das widerspricht seiner ampelkarte
und jetzt können wir mal weiter lesen
also hier sagt jetzt in diesem zitat in
der sechsten zeile unsere absicht ist es
die menschen von ihren falschen
vorstellungen abzubringen als ob gott
ein absoluter fürst sei nach willkür
verfährt und wenig geeignet und würdig
ist geliebt zu werden
diese ansichten über gott sind umso
schlimmer als das wesen der frömmigkeit
nicht darin besteht in zu fürchten
sondern ihn über alles zu lieben
dies ist nicht möglich ohne kenntnis der
vollkommenheit solchen die liebe die er
verdient und die glückseligkeit aller
derer die ihn lieben entspringt also
hier willkür willkür ist in dieser zeit
sehr negativ konnotierte willkür ist
bloßer zufall bloße beliebig große
beliebigkeit und das ist natürlich zu
einem rationalisten wie leibniz sehr
unsympathisch leibnitz möchte alles
immer verstehen vielleicht jetzt muss
alles rational erklärbar sein also dass
gott irgendwie diese sachen hier zuletzt
in der welt muss einem logischen grund
haben das muss sich rational zeigen
lassen und das ist jetzt diese absicht
von leibnitz und jetzt haben sie schon
wie im referat sehr richtig genannt
diese diese welten wir haben darüber
kurz gesprochen
weiß jemand von ihnen was eine mögliche
welt ist man jetzt komme auf diese these
dass wir hier
in der besten aller möglichen welten
leben nach leibnitz also obwohl wir es
hier in dieser welt mit diesen ganzen
leiden zu tun haben wohl wir es hier mit
erdbeben mit krankheiten mit morgen mit
liegen zu tun haben
trotzdem würde leiden zu these vertreten
ist diese welt in der diese maler alle
vorkommen immer noch die beste aller
möglichen welten
es müssen uns natürlich erst mal
überlegen was ist überhaupt die welt
nach leibnitz hansen idee durchlese es
mal vor und können wir darüber noch
genauer diskutieren welt nenne ich hier
die ganze volk und das ganze bei
einander aller bestehenden dinge
damit man nicht sagen kann mehrere
welten könnten zu verschiedenen zeiten
an verschiedenen orten bestehen man muss
sie insgesamt für eine welt rechnen oder
wie man will von universum erfüllte man
jederzeit an jedem ort
es bleibt dennoch war dass man sie auf
unendlich viele arten hätte erfüllen
können und dass es unendlich viele
mögliche welten gibt von denen gott mit
notwendigkeit mit notwendigkeit die
beste erwählt hat da er nichts ohne
höchste von uns tut also vernunft und
verstand kann man jetzt hier zusammen
nehmen als die these ist wir leben der
besten aller möglichen welten und diese
beste aller möglichen welten ist nicht
irgendwie zufällig willkürlich wie wenn
diese vorherigen zitat hatten hier sehen
ob man hier nach willkür fährt nicht
willkürlich
das ist immer schlecht willkürlich für
die sozialisten das kontingent zufällig
nicht verständlich sondern sie ist
notwendig und sie entspricht
die höchsten von unten prinzipien das
ist zwar ein rad zu nisten ganz wichtig
tja was ist jetzt eine mögliche welt
haben sie ideen geben sie mal ein
beispiel von der möglichen will ganz
konkretes beispiel
welche bestimmten
das programm sieht man zum beispiel
wieder
die höhe
ganz zum beispiel
ja dass ich denke dass es logisch
möglich also eine mögliche welt ist nach
leibnitz eine logisch mögliche welt und
ich denke es wäre logisch möglich dass
wir nicht mehr schlafen wobei natürlich
dann unsere endlichkeit auch betroffen
wären endlich gewesen scheint irgendwie
logisch notwendigerweise schlafen zu
müssen vielleicht aber vielleicht
könnten wir auch uns ausruhen auf mehr
antreffen könnte man sich überlegen
nämlich außerirdische die auch endlich
sind aber sie wäre generieren auf den
anderen als sie ganz einfach andere
mögliche welt wäre diese welt also die
gesamte welt wie sie ist ohne diesen
stift auf dem tisch dieser stift ist
jetzt natürlich noch da aber eine andere
mögliche welt wäre diese welt ohne den
stift dies logisch möglich vorstellbar
was wären denn jetzt anders gefragt eine
unmögliche welt es ist schon ein
bisschen schwieriger
das ist eine unmögliche welt mal an alle
was könnte eine unmögliche welt sein
wir haben gesagt eine mögliche welt ist
eine logisch mögliche welt und es nicht
logisch unmöglich dass der stifter nicht
mehr
es ist jetzt eine unmögliche welt ja
genau ich denke das ist ein sehr gutes
beispiel oder da hatten sie sich noch
gemeldet
genau der stift liegt hier und er lebt
hier nicht das wäre eine welt und das
wäre nach leibnitz eine unmögliche welt
warum weil diese welt die prinzipien
unseres verstandes die gefahr bringen
würden hier immer verstand gottes das
würde also die rationalität gottes in
bedrängnis bringen und gott ist verleiht
nicht vollständig rational
da waren noch eine meldung
nur nicht mehr
wie zb die karte
es ist eine spannende frage ob eine
mögliche welt möglich wäre ohne raum ob
raum notwendig ist logisch notwendig ich
denke bleibt jetzt würde sagen ja aber
ich sehe jetzt zumindest keinen
logischen widerspruch man könnte jetzt
sagen raum und zeit hang aufs engste
logisch miteinander zusammen
kein raum ohne zeit so und sofern es
sich um eine welt handelt die geschöpft
wurde muss sie begrenzt sein also muss
sie räumlich und zeitlich seien
irgendwie so könnte man argumentieren
als sagen aus der notwendigkeit der
schöpfung folgt die endlichkeit und
endlichkeit ist immer verbunden mit
räumlicher endlichkeit und zeitlicher
endlichkeit dann würde ich sagen ist es
notwendig sie doch ganz hinten ja
alle
das potenziell
nicht nächstes jahr
das okay
nur einmal
es ist jede werbung zu machen
perfekt
alles möglich
außer der möglichkeit dass diese staaten
existieren würden
peter wie siehst du es
die sich aus dem
danke sagen
also ich hab das jetzt
so wiesen
ja
zusätzlich ganz grundsätzlich
eine wette ist
die hand ist und dass sich der mann an
und sagt ein paar meter möglich sein
dass und zum beispiel existentes ist ja
wenn der pakt ist und wenn auf der
anderen seite aber klagt seine
wichtigste parameter ist
nichts
und nicht nur das
wieder also wenn sie in logischen
widerspruch hätten ja bitte ich glaube
ich dass welt sein
er ist soweit ist mit ihnen schon
ich bin mit ausgesagt also eine existenz
eine eigenschaft zu leben
kommen sondern inexistent ist schon ein
und so ein wenig
die gruppen haben
das hat dem ganzen anderen hängt zum
beispiel auch die
diese freundlichkeit
ich kann das nicht endlich mal weiter
also dahin ganz viel dran
ich glaube man kann sich so leicht zu
klammern verleitung es ist sehr schwer
vorstellbar
herauszuheben
wenn man sich die welt
das rathaus vorstellten das ist für uns
ganz schwer vorstellbar
klaus sieht man das ganze immer noch
stehen aber das muss stehen welt zu sein
deswegen geht er davon aus dass dieses
kartenhaus eigentlich das einzig
wirklich möglich und auch das beste
[Musik]
ist eigentlich meine
ein gutes beispiel denke ich
als charakter
diese wollen sie es schon schwer wiegen
überhaupt eine welt erschaffen
die stehen die quasi sich selbst
widerspricht wieder einen architekten
vertrauen und um möglichkeiten zur
bekämpfung zu bauen
das wie
wir haben die beste
was anderes
und da hast du einen wichtigen punkt
angesprochen nämlich gesagt das ist
kartenhaus das hat ein fundament es ist
ein art system ist es also ein logisches
system was sich der leitende
zusammenbaut und in diesem system hat
alles sein ort jetzt müssen wir mal kurz
weitergehen weil jetzt kommt noch ein
wirklich wichtiger punkt und weil jetzt
nämlich dieser einwand kommt gleich
jetzt kommt noch kurz ja groß war
neben
universum
wie wäre es denn dort lässt
deshalb wissen
das kann er ja auch in jedes universum
geben das heißt es für toyota leicht
möglich sein
eben da existiert nach dem großen gehen
zum beispiel
wer sein
die experimente
neben geschaffen hat diese aussage ist
kein gott liegen gewesen was
seinesgleichen und der burg
nicht sagen solche spielchen sind für
ein
theologischen denkens
inside
wir werden nicht das ist ja voraus zu
sein
und wir haben das selbst der schweiz
voraus die für so einen deutlich auf
deren schaffen und die ist nicht
gar nicht möglich
ein schäfer der mit einer schaltung
nichts zu tun hat es wird auch das
klischee des omaha ein
er schafft diese welt gebaut
es steht aber diese taten auch nicht
mehr erleben konnte
ist eine maximale rennen und suchen
es ist kein gag ist was macht ihr da
macht das ist
werfen können
was mit verschiedenen bällen und
diversen turnieren also haben sie schon
viel zu komplizierte zu gehen ständig
bewacht wird auch kleine weiter
und ein weiterer punkt wäre auch noch
warum es so was widersprüchlich es nicht
sein könnte dass gott an den verstand
gebunden ist gott ist an die gesetze des
verstandes gebunden als der verstand
letztendlich gibt gott vor wasser zu tun
hat die absolute vernunft und nicht gott
bestimmt die vernunft wir sind wir die
spannende frage was hängt jetzt genannt
ja das ist ein guter punkt ist dann also
das ist ein sehr guter punkt jetzt ist
gott allmächtig wenn er sich an die
vorgaben des verstandes zu halten hat
wenn der weg
ja
der fertig
das gegenteil
weil er nicht als ein
[Musik]
diese gebracht sondern abzuwarten
und wie verloren
ist nicht eine station menschlichen
wesens oder irgendwas in der welt sei
und wir fuhren die welt haben dann muss
man zu verfassen
also es ist dass diesen aspekt hier den
kann man nicht groß genug einschätzen
weil bildung verwendet nicht ein
phänomen
das ist großer aufgekommen vorstellen
stellt sich die frage sogar
geht so
dann wäre ebenso ein widerspruch nicht
anzeigen von mächtigkeit gottes sein
widerspruch zu erzeugen oder zu
konstruieren sondern eben gerade ein
zeichen seiner effizienz also also diese
all mächtigkeit ist ganz eng verbunden
mit dem verstand weil mächtigkeit nach
leibnitz immer auch eine konstruktive
mächtigkeit bedeutet und eben nicht
destruktiv ist und auch nichts
willkürliches das ist natürlich mit
prämisse die man nicht unbedingt im
schenken muss aber in diesem setting in
seinem in dieser rahmenbedingungen ist
es eben so dass der verstand die
allmacht nicht einschränkt weil
irgendwelche widersprüchlichen dinge
damit nicht möglich sind es sind eben
gerade besteht all mächtigkeit ist immer
rational mächtigkeit vernünftigkeit aber
das ist ein guter einwand gewesen den
man sich sehr sehr zu recht den man sich
jetzt nicht überleben kann
dass menschen die beiden klappt es noch
nicht
hier
das heißt ja gegeben auf dem menschen
andere probleme und widersprüche der
welt meines erkennen zu können probleme
lösbar
auch in diesem fall machen
vorstellen
hat der mensch etwas zu schaffen
der bericht enthält ist dann ist das
und das was du gerade sachs dieses nicht
perfekt das ist gerade das manometer
physikum das ist also die grundstruktur
unserer endlichkeit die sich durch alle
bereiche durchzieht sowohl uns am
handeln dass wir moralisch böse handeln
können als auch in der anfälligkeit für
krankheiten erdbeben und
naturkatastrophen
zu sehen hätte er seine besucher für ihn
alles
würde er nur noch sagen
keine probleme
die keine mittel
der blut sehen
gott tatsächlich
das ist eine erwartet also war das
gedacht haben der natürlich auch noch
nie im sand es nicht auf den menschen
dürfen ein gewinn der sie in dieser alte
mann hat alle diese mit perfektion der
berlin 2
wir haben immer wieder durch
innovationen ein
wochen
wobei natürlich dieses endlich erkennen
durchaus eine unter logische qualität
hat also man kann natürlich dann schon
fragen wie hast dieses endliche kennen
als ein faktum der welt der schöpfung zu
dieser all mächtigkeit und jetzt kommen
eben diese argumente diese
gegenargumente kann ein gegner diesem
argument nicht beikommen sowie da
vielleicht auf unsere schlussfolgerung
mit einem entgegengesetzten argument
antworten er wird sagen die welt hätte
ja sinnlos und ohne leiden sein können
wäre das jetzt nicht die beste aller
möglichen welten wenn es hier keinen
neid gibt also wir streichen jetzt das
mal um moral raus und das malen physikum
[Musik]
ist es dann nicht die beste die bessere
aller möglichen welten ist das nicht
eine bessere welt also stellen sich
diese welt hier so vor wie sie ist - ein
zahnschmerz einer person irgendwo auf
der welt - ein zahnschmerz - eine
sekunde zahnschmerzen minus 0 5 sekunden
zahnschmerzen wir lösen eine person
etwas von ihrem zahnschmerz ist dass da
nicht doch eine bessere welt von jetzt
hat der peter schon richtig gesagt
bleibt es hängt alles miteinander
zusammen wir dürfen die welt nicht so
aussehen als ob du hier was raus nehmen
so modular oder additiv wir legen hier
was hin belegen hier was hin sondern
etwas wegnehmen deswegen fand ich diese
metapher dieses kartenhaus sehr gut wenn
du das haus ziehen dann hängen davon
andere dinge ab die auch in bewegung
geraten
und das ganze wird dann sehr sehr
schnell instabil ist sicher weiter
wissen muss man sagt jetzt leibnitz auf
dieses diesen einwand dass in jeder
möglichen welt alles miteinander in
verbindung steht jede wie das universum
ist ein ganzes aus einem stück gleich
einem ozean die geringste bewegung
breitet sich in beliebige entfernung aus
wenn sie auch schwächer und schwächer
wird entsprechend dieser entfernung
das hat gott ein für alle mal alles im
voraus geregelt
ihr der die gebiet die guten schlechten
handlung und alessandro voraussage und
jedes ding hat vor seiner existenz ideal
liter zu dem entschluss beigetragen der
über das dasein aller dinge gefasst
wurde darum kann in der welt nichts ohne
schaden an seiner wesensart oder wie bei
einer zahl wenn man will an seine
numerische individualität verändert
werden wenn somit das geringste übel
dass in der wind alt eintritt fehlt
zahnschmerz eine sekunde zahnschmerz
fehlte es wäre nicht mehr diese welt die
alles in allem von dem sie außer
wählenden schöpfer als die beste
gefunden worden ist
ich habe es nicht vergessen also hier
geht es um einen auserwählten schöpfer
also gott entscheidet sich so wie wir in
einem vorherigen zitat gesagt haben gott
entscheidet sich nicht willkürlich oder
zufällig beliebig gott bindet sich nicht
die augen zu und greift und so eine urne
von möglichen welt und greift in eine
heraus so könnte man sich ja auch
schöpfung vorstellen beliebig
beliebigkeit sondern gott wende die
verstandes prinzipien an und konstruiert
oder schafft eine welt die in sich so
kohärent ist dass sie als system dem
prinzip des verstandes maximal gerecht
wird
weil alles hinter zusammenhängt also man
kann dieses zusammenhängen auch hohl ist
paulis muslim und tourismus
pulis muss ist vom griechischen wort
holders heißt ganz also ein system in
dem jedes glied miteinander
zusammenhängen aufeinander verwiesen ist
jetzt gibt's genau idee an
aber er war das böse geschieden
das ist
da braucht es besteht und dass dort dann
befreien will ist nicht neu dass man
daraus was gutes tun können aber dafür
müsste vorher schon
gesehen greift nachdem es gedauert
greife ein undichter das sind ja zwei
grundlegende aspekte eines was ich das
bezahlen also der
die grundkonstruktion der schöpfung und
die andere ist die dann hier am 10
frage inwiefern der mensch sozusagen das
dessert an welche rolle - böses spiel
und so weiter das ist ganz einfach das
zusammenzubringen was glaube ich für
diesen gedanken hier
das kann man sagt uns können sie
vielleicht erklärt diesen schlag des
schmetterlings sehe vor dass von dem
beben ist also der mensch ist nicht
eigentlich nicht in der lage die werde
ich eben wieder fragen angemessen zu
sagen wenn ich etwas als problematische
bildeten zu stellen ist es nur meinen
sie
und es ist kurzsichtig zu sagen das sei
ein problem
weil ich da eigentlich
dass ich wenn ich diese zahl ständig
gebe sehr viele namen bakterien zum
beispiel in diese zahl schwer zu glauben
und sterben müssen also der tasche
gezogen
diese sache ist wir brauchen einen
schädigen indem sie daten kann es bei
uns nicht geben denn jedes nach einem
seliger welt da gibt es längst reagiert
sodass einwohner des marktes er
aufklärer ist ein ganz komisches selten
die beiden für die damen ist eigentlich
der kostenlos ist ein kristalle in jeder
die gleichen
wertvolle klein geworden für weniger
bleibt verhalten als den folgen menschen
im was man vorher an insel alter egos
marburg und das in einer wirklichen
geschichte denn der mensch etwas
schlechter als diese versorgung in der
welt wahrnimmt und solnhofen 30 eg kommt
zu sagt gott als schöpfer scheinbar
nicht richtig glauben
ein einziges
nicht erkennen zu können das alles könne
sich seinen persönlichen kleinen so
eingeschränkt und er meinte dass seine
biografie sein leben sei in der lage
schlecht
ja du hast hier noch glaub ich sie jetzt
zu recht auf diesen schmetterlingseffekt
so kann man den ja nennen hingewiesen
also noch so unscheinbare handlungen
oder aktivitäten aktionen ereignisse in
der welt können auf lange frist sind auf
unendliche frist in unendlicher
perspektive die uns als menschen nicht
möglich ist zu ganz entscheidenden
veränderungen führen wir können es nicht
absehen
das ist dieses argument von leibnitz
also wir in unserer endlichkeit haben
eigentlich gar nicht die möglichkeit
epidemisch wirklich zu beurteilen ob
jetzt etwas in dieser welt wirklich
schlecht ist weil wir es immer vom ende
her sehen müssen und das ende ist
letztendlich die unendlichkeit und die
unendlichkeit steht uns nicht zur
verfügung als perspektive weil wir
metaphysische begrenzte wesen sind
gemäss diesem manometer physikum also
endlich wissen
entscheiden
wohl hier in seinem sport einfach das
dann kann die größte nicht sinnvoll
da kann ein massenchor sinnlos die leute
hochzeit nichts mehr auch ein
diverse möglich
dass gerade die st
das ist eine entscheidung darüber
bremen handelt
für die generation
und ein ende der welt beschichtet und
kann
alles klappen hügeln und für werden
folgen
jahrhundert
hier noch so ein einwand zwar kann man
sich wenden ohne sünden ohne unglück
vorstellen und so etwas daraus machen
wie die romane von utopien
aber diese welten würden im übrigen der
unsrigen erheblich nach stehen die
werden also schlechter wir wissen
außerdem das oft ein übel an gut bewirkt
welches ohne dieses übel nicht
eingetroffen wäre oft haben sogar zwei
übel ein großes gut zur folge gehabt
also wir sehen eben nicht diese
konsequenzen ab das ist das problem
ich lese gerade noch so ein paar
anwenderin habe ich sie nicht vergessen
etwas saures scharfes oder bitteres
gefällt auch besser als zucker der
schatten lässt die farbe stärker
hervortreten und selbst eine dissonanz
am rechten platz erhebt hat die harmonie
seiltänzer im begriffe hinabzustürzen
sollen uns in schrecken versetzen trauer
spiele sollen uns bis zu tränen
ergreifen kostet man die gesundheit aus
und dank man gott dafür wenn man niemals
krank gewesen ist und muss nicht
meistens ein kleines übel das gute
fühlbarer sozusagen größer werden lassen
das sitzt frage die leighton ist stellt
der rhetorischen frage sagen sie ja oder
nein was sagen sie
weiters stellt diese frage eigentlich
nicht an uns sind für ihn ist die frage
selbst erklären natürlich ja aber was
würden sie dazu sagen ja
man kann das gut gehen 127 veränderungen
kann man ja nur geben
wenig geld etwas verändert und das gute
essen warten die entweder etwas
schlechter bildung von
die nation er vorher ausbessern sondern
es würden aber das gleicht es ist wieder
da
sie zusammen
fast nebenbei das andere
7 in der station oder sollte sportlich
er das geschafft und ist immer so
genau das wäre das prinzip des
kontrastes nur der opposition gut nur im
kontrast zur bösen zu schlecht es kann
sich nur als solches behaupten wenn es
sich abhebt von etwas und von dem es
sich abhebt das ist das schlecht die
frage ist natürlich wie man so
argumentiert hat man da nicht ein
dualismus holt man sich da nicht so ein
wesen tourismus rein so sagt gut und
böse sind die polare gegensätze die nur
im gegenzug existieren können hätte das
übel ja auch so ein bisschen eigene
existenz in mir scheint ich weiß nicht
sie noch kurze
in seinem verein dem thema qualität
wir wollen daher ist die wir qualitäts
der intensiven alles das gesetzliche
system also ausgeben
das abstellen zu können dieses dienstes
der umsatzschwund sein das ist ein
entspanntes verhältnis menschen erklären
mein geld
naja als auch dieses moralische übel und
diese freiheit ist nach leibnitz für den
menschen nur endlich das ist immer
etliche freiheit unendliche freiheit ist
eben immer schon der verlockung etwas
böses zu tun aber eben nicht der
notwendigkeit das ist eben auch ganz
wichtig sind so ein paar argumente
ja also wir hier dann seinen dritten
zeige nur aus mangel an achtsamkeit
verkleinern wir unsere güter und es
bedarf einiger übel um diese achtsamkeit
ist diskret tief was sie meinten da
dieses deskriptive dieses nur
beschreiben die um diese achtsamkeit uns
wach werden zu lassen
während wir für gewöhnlich krank und
selten bei guter gesundheit dann würden
wir die größe dieses gutes wunderbar
schätzen und unsere leiden weniger
beachten aber es aber ist es nicht trotz
alledem besser dass die gesundheit an
der regel die krankheit selten ist dass
all dieses die argumentation über die
kontrastieren heraus
ja wir kriegen vielleicht noch ein paar
andere zitate
das ist jetzt noch ein wichtiges zitat
das sollten wir noch kurz lesen da geht
es jetzt hier um dieses mal um mit der
physik um das hatten wir ganz am anfang
der sitzung aufgeworfen diese frage was
ist das eigentlich genau wir hatten dann
gesagt dass es diese diese ähnlichkeit
hat die die grobstruktur die
rahmenbedingungen für uns menschen
jetzt sagt er hier si ds ist und dem
hahn um sie nun ist und die boni also
wenn gott ist woher kommt das übel
und wenn er nicht existiert woher das
gute die alten verlegten die ursache des
bösen die materie die sie verschaffen
und von gott unabhängig hielten welche
position klingt hier durch diese
unabhängig von gott unabhängige materie
des bösen welche positionen hat in
unserem seminar diese auffassung
vertreten
denkt sie noch mal zurück augustinus
richtet sich dagegen und auch mutter
genau die man nicht hegen aber wo finden
wir dass wir alles sein von gott her
leiten die die wir alles sein von
gottheiten die quelle des bösen die
antworten also jetzt die frage woher
kommt die quelle des bösen die quelle
des bösen ist jetzt wie wir vorhergesagt
hatten die ursache dieser beiden maler
also mal um orale und mal um physikum
woher kommt das eigentum hier ist jetzt
die antwort darauf die antwort man muss
sie in der idealen natur des geschöpfes
aufsuchen
soweit diese natur in den ewigen
wahrheiten des glücklichen verstandes
unabhängig von seinem willen enthalten
ist
es gibt nämlich in der kreatur eine
ursprüngliche unvollkommenheit vor aller
sünde also vor den mahlow moral noch
drüber oder drunter wie man es nimmt
also noch vorgelagert weil begrenzung
zum wesen der kreatur gehört daher kann
sie nicht alles wissen sich täuschen und
andere fehler begehen
das ist jetzt vielleicht noch so ein
zitat an dem er noch ein bisschen
verweilen sollen bevor wir dann zu kant
übergeben auch noch eine kurzes referat
hören werden so könnte aber wie können
sie jetzt da sinn machen da peter wie
würdest du würdest du es als theologe
sehen so dieses mal um metaphysik um die
sind diese begrenzung dieser die
notwendige begrenzung kreatur ist ja
diese schöpfung dieses kreatürliche
als ich hätte als rückfrage ein dicker
als theologe ist und die frage als
philosoph also offensichtlich muss doch
nach leibnitz schöpfung notwendig immer
schöpfung eines endlichen wesen zeit
oder gott könnte doch wo auch
theologischer perspektive nicht etwas
unendliches erschaffen als kreatur
zweitens vorbringen ist widerspricht
zutiefst wissen ja sehr von antiken
philosophie beeinflusst und denken über
leiten was sehr stark auf den
dass einige kosten fokussiert platin und
so kommen dass er selber hinter gott
kann nur eines sein und der gar nicht
ein zweites was er die
schöpfungsgeschichte behauptet na also
so ein abbild gottes letzten aber nach
seinen bildern es nicht
die fähigkeit
besonders weil leider ist natürlich
durch die vernunft des menschen
geblieben
der mensch hat etwas glücklich an sich
in sich diesen ganzen monat ist ein ganz
anderes thema sein
das ist eine schöpfung des ordners will
das ist ja so dass es sich materie in
der witz und geist müssen erhalten dass
bei den partien zuvor gestellt
alles vernunft und materie sind in jedem
kleinsten atom enthalten menschheit
lichtwerk ein individuum in dem sinne
ist sondern eine consumer barth aus
geist materien entität hochkomplexes
sehr selten dass dieser gott kann also
nicht einen zweiten goldregen gleitet
erschaffen sondern alles was das wort
hervor
muss ein gegenüber der effizienten sein
diese dieses defizit zeigt sich dann
durch tätigkeit zu sein also das
kartenausgebende ausgaben wobei man sie
jetzt fragen könnte der schöpfung muss
gott notwendigerweise schöpfen muss gott
ja alles gott muss musste warum muss er
überhaupt schöpfen waren musste warum
muss da eine kreatur überhaupt entstehen
die dann endlich ist würde seine
fähigkeiten
als es ist besser für gott ist es ihr
seine an mächtigkeit entsprechen diese
schöpfung durchzuführen mit diesen
ganzen mal ramallah und so weiter und so
fort als wenn er nicht schöpfen würden
der schule der die seite eingesetzt ist
es kein mieter stellung des gehörte zur
vollkommenheit gottes dass er in der
lage ist etwas hingegen über müssen
vollkommen und jetzt kommt aber noch
eine verschärfung ins spiel bei genau
genommen gehört auch dann zur
vollkommenheit gottes die möglichkeit
auch die wirklichkeit etwas
unvollkommenes schaffen was aber in sich
dank freiheit irgendwie sich ihm
entgegen setzen kann also gott schafft
etwas was es war endlich ist aber was
doch irgendwie aufgrund seiner freiheit
unendlich ist und dann wiederum seine
freiheit auch beschränken könnte
zumindest wenn es nicht mehr ihm
gehorchen
aber dann könnte man die elektrisch
sagen ja daran besteht eben gerade die
all mächtigkeit eben auch sowas semi
autonomes neben sich zu tun
nur ein beispiel
gegenwärtig wissenschaftstheorie tisch
der künstlichen intelligenz aus was
macht das es so das thema technologie
historisch interessant es geht in der
weiterentwicklung von
harald otto und so weiter ist der
ansicht die logische gründe warum ist es
ein besonderes spiel
deswegen weil wir damit eine
verselbstständigung des verfolgen braten
aus dem künstliche intelligenz ist
insofern ein konto als die maschine der
buddha thema macht ein eigenleben für
was von st
also thematische unbeachtet was man dann
nicht mehr unter kontrolle
da tritt etwas entscheidung was sehen
der es gebaut hat hat nicht mehr zur
verfügung stehen das auto fertig stellen
außerdem welche
vor dem
und man
das auto gebaut hat dafür nicht mehr zur
rechenschaft ziehen weil der besagten
das auto gebaut mit ihren schreiben
und das beste daran ist genau das was
diesen job los gedanken beim ein bild
steht richtig vollkommen ist etwas für
eine vorgebrachten es dann wenn es den
erfolg bringende nach einem seltsamen
weil sie nicht mehr gehorchen sondern
sendung von suchenden ist dass das frei
ist zu sagen haben könnte fast sagen
kann also sage danke
die seele des menschen den
schöpferischen dass sie von der freiheit
des menschen erzeugen und damit ist
etwas geschaffen worden
genauso diese spannung ist also die
diese freiheit des menschen die eine
autonomie hat absolutheit in gewissem
grade beschränkt einerseits gottes
allmacht ein weil sie sich nämlich gegen
ihn wenden kann wenn ich zum beispiel
gottes gebot nicht gehorche auf der
anderen seite aus einer anderen
perspektive wird dadurch habe gerade die
allmacht bestätigt weil gott etwas so
autonomes erschaffen kann das sich ihm
entgegen setzt also wie man es
betrachtet kann man es einmal als eine
bestätigung seiner allmacht und einmal
nicht
roboter wirtschaft der wirklich sehr
gestellt intelligent ist deshalb
besonders gut
nicht ein schlechter sein produkt nicht
unter kontrolle mit gesang schlechte in
die jüngeren zu machen
machen was soll ich da nein das haben
das ist einfach mit fernbedienung risiko
der ingenieurskunst etwas zu
kontrollieren muss man nicht nur
gekommen
etwas was einen millionen stellen
gefährlich ist paradox aber irgendwie
faszinierend also die fehler des
menschen machen seine perfektion aus
jetzt kann man sie haben nicht vergessen
noch eine frage die ich jetzt
anschließen möchte wenn du es tags die
fehler machen seine perfektion aus wie
kann man sich ja fragen also was für
fehler sind es zum beispiel moralische
fehler also zum beispiel dass man um
moral dass der mensch sündigt genau
liegt dann geh meine privatsphäre deine
perversion story des guten zu grunde
jetzt also man von dieser ökologischen
sich her ist dann das übel nach dieser
sicht nur einen mangel an sein
oder könnte da eigentlich auch eine
gewisse positivität gewesen sein
wir müssen andere weise in seinem
perfektion kann den fehler begehen und
ist dann auch
[Musik]
genau in dieser mangelhaftigkeit würde
ja dann wieder hier diese autonomie
bestätigt wäre wenn es eine zurechenbare
schuld wer also hier sieht man bei
leugnet es ist nicht mehr nur eine reine
private ist kommt so am ende noch ein
text den er heute nicht mehr lesen
können
aber es sagt das böse entsteht aus einer
trägheit aus anderen so eine art von
schwerkraft aus einer sie kennen das
wenn sie einen kleinen eine starke eine
schwere bahn auf einem gleis anschieben
wollen oder so an gewicht in bewegung
setzen wollen dann müssen sie das
ziemlich viel druck erst mal ausüben bis
es in bewegung kommt dann irgendwann
läuft das heißt dieses gefährt setzt ihn
so eine trägheit kraft entgegen und
bleibt jetzt bestimmt das böse im falle
des menschen des moralischen als alle
seine trägheit kraft wir lassen uns von
gott nicht bewegen zum guten sondern wir
leisten widerstand
wo jetzt die frage ist diese
widerständigkeit wie sie beiträgen
objekten zu finden ist ist diese trägt
heizkraft nur eine mangelhafte qualität
oder liegt darin auch schon so eine art
positive energie die wollen damit dem
mit der perversion story verbindung
bringen könnte müssen jetzt nicht mehr
genau im detail darauf eingehen aber ich
glaube man sieht hier schön anhand
dieser verwobenheit diese verschiedenen
aspekte dass das mal um moral nicht nur
ein primitives phänomen ist sondern dass
ich darin irgendwie eine perfektion auch
zeigt im gras sind diese
eigenständigkeit menschen die dann
natürlich wieder zurück wirkt auf gottes
allem warten sind dieser schön
mitfavorit igor gebracht hast eines
ingenieurs der 1
total autonomes gefährt konstruiert was
in denen geleitet wird
das hat natürlich auch etwas
dramatisches gibt's ja auch in die
geister die ich rief
faustische und kritische und und aber
auch pro metrische und ich dachte auch
so ein bisschen noch an frankenstein wo
man dann so einen künstlichen menschen
schafft na das ist ja auch der moderne
prometheus das kann damit gleiten
da ist die perfektion
er macht was genau aber der unterschied
zu einem ingenieur ist ja der dass gott
alles auch vorher weil es also beim
ingenieur ist es so er sagt ach du liebe
güte ist konnte ich ja dann vielleicht
auch nicht wissen was jetzt passiert
oder so dass es sich mal mehr
entgegenstellen würde dieser frage
standen zu gott ist es ja so dass der
immer alles auch weiß alles will als er
lässt sich dadurch nicht überraschend er
kann nicht überrascht werden durch
irgendeine sehr sehr intelligenter
schöpfung die dann immer ein kleid das
kann ich nicht leiden
diese
kontrollierte und dieses entgleiten ist
eben gerade die bestätigung seiner
allmacht und das ist ein bisschen
paradox wie kann ein gleiten die
eigenmächtigkeit bestärken geraten
eigentlich würde man sagen einkleiden
kann immer nur der mächtigkeit
entgegenlaufen aber hier ist es eben
dass die eine mächtigkeit eine seine
positiven entgleiten führt ich denke so
kann man es darstellen
besonders mit hohe autorität
ausgestattet
die ihre und ergebnis steigern können
das ist ein zeichen von autorität
schwäche heftiger autorität aus dem auto
weil man so schön das ist kein stern
zeichnet seine stelle gut werden ist
autoritär habe immer angst vor
kontrollverlust muss seinen hintern
gegeben hat
wenn es etwa im nordirak kamen
es war ein kampfspiel werden jährlich
der meinung sein aber sobald es draußen
das ist halt das möglich
sozusagen
ist das der schöpfung frei angeles im
körper neben untreue
da wirklich was gut und was über
dienstliche anders
das leuchtet mir ist hier ein ja ich
glaube damit hammer eigentlich jetzt die
den zentralen punkt bei leibnitz
besprochen und der zentrale punkt ist
wie wir gesehen haben dass manu
metaphysik um also das ist diese neue
dimension des bösen
die leibniz ins spiel bringt er wer big
prägt auch diesen begriff als erster
diesen begriff gab es davor so nicht
diese begriffe mal um moral und mal und
physik um mit mir wie gesagt schon bei
augustinus aber diese neue dimension die
das ganze von letzten ersten grund her
betrachtet das ist die leibliche
perspektive auf das böse das übel die
dann natürlich mit dem verstand und dem
willen gottes wieder zusammenhängt